good morning good morning good morning
Claudia good morning Jackie good morning
toasters oh my god a morning if honestly
if we didn't stop like I probably
wouldn't been able to stop the entire
show we should do one no we should do
one random show we're like no one's
watching maybe I'm like a Wednesday
Wednesday's are so where you do the
whole show in good-morning Millennials
voice morning we are so excited to be
back on this beautiful bright and sunny
Monday in New York City how's everyone
feeling today I'm doing okay I didn't
take my vitamins so I'm a little slow
but I'm feeling very slow and I had like
a little bit of a bellyache before bed
cuz we shoved our faces at nobody last
night and then like I got home and like
ignored the bellyache and I just woke up
not feeling right - you know - yeah a
little stuff how do you feel now I'm
feeling alive cuz I'm on the toast yeah
the toast is a great place to be on
Monday morning we have a great show for
you today not only ever even hate you
with the fast I story so you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast but we have a
very special guest
Kurt elympios yes we're so excited to
talk to her we got a lot of questions
for Corinne and it's like been a while
since we got some good scoop I know I'm
ready for and she always has the best
scoop right she doesn't even have to try
and she just has squishy his new
hairstyle we saw it yeah very ariana
grande yeah you guys are gonna see it so
if you do have questions for Corinne
she'll be coming on later in the show
I'm watching on Facebook Jackie's on
YouTube so make sure to leave a comment
asking her anything you want to know and
we will get it to her as long as it's
appropriate so glad that I won't like a
pond they can't respond to you and I
know it's hard
honestly let me they can look guys does
it sound like a plan to me just because
we really don't have another choice you
know I know honestly like we need to get
an audience up in this joint
okay fan Friday yeah we're bringing back
fan Friday shoes of their choice
it just doesn't matter it's better when
not in yeah um okay how was your weekend
I was just about to ask you that
question
maybe weekend was fantastic let me tell
you why I slept probably 12 hours each
I'm really feeling like a star and not
only did I sleep a lot and get a lot of
relaxation in I accomplished so much my
apartment yeah you did oh my god I took
it from zero to hero it
still not 100% done but I started the
weekend at like 50% done I'm at 75 now
and it feels really good because I was
living in squalor
like I think sound and like I'm shocked
because Jackie is like not that you
could clean but you're like organized
yeah and the fact like there were still
boxes was crazy and I know that they
weren't yours and they were out of your
control cuz it was Zack Zack has so much
stuff but like I was you know what I was
I was shocked and dismayed no and we
FaceTime and I almost wish I had taken
pictures of what things look like the
force I could show you guys how hard I
worked but I know that Claudia knows
like you saw my closet before I made
those shelves and also just like a shout
out to me because okay I turned my actor
I took my ass down to Home Depot I
picked out all of the hardware for
shelves not one person helped me they're
like a small Frau girl by like building
shelves give me some help I can't eat
and I shan't yeah and I took it all with
me ie bird back home with all of my
shelves in tow and handyman did put up
two rods but then I put up all the
shelving you do yes because it's my
second time building those shelves I
don't even so I knew what I needed the
supplies have anyone like needs some
shelf consultation I'm your girl I'm
very cold
I'm here's some nasality allergies mixed
with potentially a cold from singing
with the air on you know I have built up
an immunity whereas I actually get a
cold if I don't sleep with the air on
interesting also I wanted you to know at
home depot they do sell ceiling fans I
saw them and I said okay I am itching
for a ceiling fan because do you have to
have an apparatus in your ceiling or to
attach the thing I haven't done enough
research I was like about to buy when
I'm wayfarer they had like glamorous
ones that like had they were like palm
tree leaves I loved it like these other
we got some new ferns are you guys into
it we're just we're now between more
than two ferns yeah between like six
ferns
we got the ferns can you believe it we
got the ferns we got the ferns we got
the ferns we got the ferns
yeah we got the birds do do do do do do
do battery great theme song for Joe and
then I was thinking sorry back to my
point about my ceiling fan was it owned
by the stupid ceiling fan like have our
handyman come up and like he would be
like sorry you don't have the apparatus
yeah and I hate when you don't have the
apparatus especially like in my building
I live in the most strict building and
litter got yelled at this morning like I
get yelled at all the time I got a nasty
that had three boxes waiting for me in
the lobby I'm like they're my ferns
please like I was just waiting to pick
him up to take him to the show I don't
wanna like leave my apartment but mr.
rictus building and I certainly would
have liked sent me a bill if like I had
the handyman come up for five seconds
I'm like he like wasn't able to like do
because there was no apparatus right so
I'm glad I didn't yeah in my next moment
I'm heavily heavily [ __ ] with a
ceiling gun okay I look forward to it I
also just want to say I did not hang the
shelves in less than seven minutes no it
took me more than seven minutes but you
know maybe I'll get there one day you
know what not everyone can be Rob's
Valletta I caught up on pump rules
ultimate you about that at another time
looks like what tomorrow does the new
episode is on tonight and I just want to
talk about the other part of my weekend
which was his birthday the greatest 21st
which was truly the greatest 24 it's
truly like the best time the most
necessary 21st no one has ever needed to
turn 21 more than Margo watch it oh my
god and honestly like she was having no
what's so crazy she was having a pit
okay so me and Michael went to the
brother judge concert where I got to
meet so many toasters and Claudette's
like it was amazing and Margo's party
didn't start to eleven so it like 10:30
we left the concert and we're going to
Marco's party to like set up and she's
having a pit in the car about which ID
to use to get into the bar where her
party isn't like a [ __ ]
you're turning 21 in an hour relax she
ended up using the real one I'm like
obviously it was fine but she literally
was so nervous up until I mean I'm so
glad that that pit has been permanently
absolved for her but one place down
thousands to go is don't you feel like
Margo's been drinking alcohol like
forever forever because we've been
drinking I'm good but it's also like
because she hangs out with like 23 24 25
26 year olds it's like that's the level
of like drink no and that's also the
level of like what her party said me
come so I guess it was a 21 year olds
party but like when it's populated by
mostly 25 year old it's like you're
getting a 25 year old five and not a
grown one stay at the club after know it
was maturely poppin it was me surely pop
and she had a great time she looks
unreal
she really oh my god she's really all
that match she looked no no all that
matters that she had the most amazing
photo in her unreal fit yeah it was
amazing so I really wish you guys could
have been there but you weren't invited
so sorry um and in case you were curious
the password to get him wasn't
interesting of course it was the dry the
I don't so it was like hey guys is there
ain't that and then you would have to
say something yeah I think anyone could
have guessed it actually I probably
wasn't super secure no they were
definitely some crash survivors but it's
fine more the merrier
the more the merrier and we had a
personal goal this weekend we hit 3000
patreon which means 3000 of you are
subscribing to our Pete Ron which means
you're getting five extra episodes a
month audio only really kind of focused
on us and life and family and love and
it the first episode was a hit oh my god
a smash success like I'm obsessed with
it me too not that I've listened to it
back maybe the feeling that I get and
also seeing all of your like responses
to it you like me just like so happy to
do it and really made me glad that we
opened up in a way that we never had
before and that's why for today's
episode we're filming today's episode
we'll probably either be up today or
tomorrow we are taking your questions
part two in the toasters after dark
group there's a whole thread with
questions so ask away so if you are a
patreon subscriber you are eligible for
our patreon totes after dark group on
Facebook so just apply and Jackie will
cross-reference make sure that you're
actually a patreon subscriber and then
voila you're ready to go but that's the
thing about like hitting your goals so
like this was a major goal like I was so
excited to hit three thousands patreon
subscribers and like now what's my new
goal ten thousand oh really oh looks
like him okay what are we gonna do I
love doing things like this okay okay
honestly I know what we're gonna do take
a bath in hot no honey mustard when we
hit 10,000 patreon subscribers not when
if we are gonna throw a massive toaster
party like we are gonna rent out space
toasters can fly in if your toaster
you're allowed to come oh my god I love
that that's such a good idea oh my god
nobody like fun drinks and everything Oh
that'll be so fun okay guys for our sake
and for your yeah let's do it
Ted doesn't pay to have subscribers
it'll probably in like six months like
I'm not gonna push it so hard but like
let me get there we are throwing a party
okay and like will reference this
episode yeah what door is it it's May
7th the day after switch's birthday I
went to Mars my friend Lacey's birthday
I can't forget what are you guys doing
for it I don't know I'm waiting for her
she always gets a birthday blues you
know like she just makes big plans and
like a day before she's like most people
like are the opposite it's like oh I
don't really want to do anything for my
birthday in the day before it's like why
don't you play me a party right honestly
I'm like I'm so over birthdays I'm like
so over I'm over my own birthday and I'm
over like having to pretend to have a
good time at other people's birthdays
agree
we are old what we're gonna do this
every year and they every year we're
gonna
Fantana bar number trend you're 19 right
yeah no like I'm down to drink but like
stop acting like you can't say anything
like a remotely offensive to someone on
their birthday like it's my birthday
like shut up [ __ ] you're annoying you
know like it went in someone's birthday
everything they did was right if you
need if they need a bottle of water go
and grab it like I'm not about that life
fine fine fine but like the day before
know the day after nobody come before
know that weekend after no I'll show up
to your party and I'll be nice showing
your birthday and that's as much as you
can expect for me like maybe a gift oh
yeah it depends on the person yeah I'm
just saying like I'm so over birthdays
like we're old [ __ ] and like it's sad
she's got some amazing gifts from the
scene yeah I bought snitch and like I
spent so much money in Sephora but like
it was worth it
snitch has the saddest makeup collection
because it's not only that it's a bunch
of drugstore products which are pretty
good but like she's not skilled enough
to like use them properly expensive drug
store products mixed with so much a
premium premium after that yes like
whenever I get big [ __ ] doesn't need
Jesus so she can hang it because like
she has it yeah
so I went to Sephora and like from
primer rosewater all the way till
eyebrow gel like I went all the way
brand new like premium NARS I bought Kat
Von D because I'm not here to stereotype
and I don't believe rumors anymore where
there's smoke there's not a fire about
the palette which I used after I get
bought it for her like when she opened I
use everything yeah it was amazing no
and they want her milk makeup foundation
like expensive [ __ ] I'm so happy for her
me too
and then it was great because she got a
whole package of fun birthday presents
from Sony clover from Kendall Olivia
knows yeah so cute everything like
initialed and so now she has what to put
her makeup in right which is a big
problem to begin with and then I got her
really cute
Sony clover fanny pack with Thomas says
so then I knew that she wanted and then
I also just got her like a boatload of
cash yeah which is what I need she's
really good yeah so almost nobody got
that shoe and I'm truly excited for it
to be over so you literally start
talking about something else yeah your
birthday I know I'm going for days the
next one let's talk about something else
the Fast Five story is that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your own morning toast okay this
first story is just like happy joyous
lovely occasion Danielle Staub got
married - Marty Caffrey I'm so hot in
the Bahamas at Luna Beach Club in Bimini
Oh
always comes back to Bimini it always
comes back to Siesta Key and Rachel and
Rachel Z and Vanessa fighting this is
the thing kind of one of my favorite
parts about being an award-winning
morning show host is that we get to have
guests on and I get to like meet people
who like debunk everything I thought
about them and Danielle Staub was really
one of those people I'm we met her I was
surprised at how like normal and like
straightforward and like smart she was
and honestly her husband is so cute I'm
so happy for her and I love her and that
reminded me of one thing I want to say
which is I love Marga Josef's me too no
no like I love her
no she's is the definition of like
having someone come on and like just
changing our entire perception but not
even that as a human being she sent me
the nicest DM I don't think I ever even
told you this
it was the most loved Lidia I'm like and
she'd have to way met her once and like
I said like on the set on our show that
her character was annoying like I said
then she sent me the most beautiful
Deanne about how she knows I'm such a
nice person and that like I'll get
through that like so nice I was like oh
my god that's so nice she will have I
don't care what she does she will have
my support till I die
oh well after she came on the show she
would have my sport - yeah and she was
everything like but all this stuff that
she was doing on the show it just wasn't
translating for me until I met her and
then it all created sense and that's why
melissa was like when we saw Melissa bur
like you don't really like Margaret and
she was like no no I'm telling you yeah
I'm you know what that's what we get for
doubting melissa gorga I just love
sometimes being proved wrong immediately
unlocking we've been proved wrong so
many times it's just like you learn
something new every day and every time
you're on the toast okay and also I
wouldn't say that she proved us wrong
but I didn't really like telly
Mellencamp when she came on I don't like
her character but that's totally
separate and she came on it was too soon
in this season to have an opinion about
it she was so having met her has meat
has made me it's like I would dislike
her on the show so much more if I never
met I just liked her bud she was a
really really pretty and her husband
like came to support they were just like
normal good people are a little
Instagram show we always talk about
Teddy Mellencamp it's like I also forget
so many of the other guests we've had
epic s please head Dorinda like oh yeah
like that man didn't even like I love
sure that doctor now
yeah me and Ramona oh my mind Ramona's
had push up yeah what a treat
what a treat who else did we have that I
just always forget we just had some
Gillian Jacobs Gilly oh my god and I've
been I've been finishing the last season
to love how is it um honestly it's okay
like I'm now I'm like less sad that
they're ending because it's not as good
okay that's fair yeah um anyways Sam
already married Marty Caffrey Oh
listen [ __ ] I didn't say anything you
can't yell at me when I say something
and when I don't pick a leg I read the
stories every single day you can't
freehub scot-free okay
they chow down and danced afterward at
the nearby whatever for with all the
important details okay so she met
married Marty Caffrey at the Luna Beach
Club in Bimini oh my god she's 55 the 55
year old her hones didn't read that I
said real housewives I abbreviate it sir
she chose some of her fellow housewives
as bridesmaids Teresa Melissa and
Margaret kind of weird to make someone
your bridesmaid literally met a year ago
but okay I love Margaret and she if I
knew her when I was getting married she
probably would've been my maid totally
and they're filming for the weddings
like the more house I smash your wedding
the more time you'll get and like some
friends you just make instantly and you
know the last life Kendall totally like
it's so wonderful to make friends late
in life no I was just saying this to
someone I like my friends are either
like friend middle school like on
originaly stay like best friends since
middle school or like Liberty people I
met a year ago like John is like
literally my best one I've only known
John for like a year two years that's
crazy I know we haven't we've only known
Kendall for a year yes I haven't like
little issues are about sir I met her at
Coachella actually a year yeah think
about that her two daughters Christine
and Gillian were also bridesmaids their
daughters are really sweet and pretty I
really like appreciate how much like she
loves her kids like would literally do
anything for them and there was like a
cute little arch there was a beach
moment it doesn't look like a ton of
money was spent but like I live and like
do you think Bravo footed the bill so
when it comes to these types of things
I've said this once I've said it before
just like having been in Bridal PR which
I literally was in for a year I was
Larry a bridal publicist oh you want to
be my bride I'll pass any anything I'd
be happy to okay but so this town works
like Robbo would never pay for the
wedding they pay for the trip but they
would never pay for the wedding but in
having your wedding on TV you're able to
barter certain things so like in
literally is written in TMZ they chow
down and dance afterwards the nearby
Hilton
rooftop that was probably pitched as a
part of the pillow story a beach club
and the luna beach club so they
definitely got some sort of barter deal
like everyone does it if you're like if
your wedding is in any magazine you got
some [ __ ] for free
great yeah good to know yeah well I'm
really happy for her me too I truly love
her
okay I feel like I've had none of them
okay next story story number two John
Cena and Nikki Bella share cryptic
messages ahead of music cryptic messages
ahead of their canceled wedding date let
me get to the hip date set already yeah
I think was like may fish shucks
okay or Nikki and John trying to tell
the world something for their wedding oh
my god I didn't realize the severity of
this it's very severe they just got
engaged I got engaged remember that was
like one of our first shows newly
announced they got engaged at
WrestleMania oh my god they were
originally set to say I do on May 5th
literally on Friday Saturday that that
changed three weeks ago and the pair of
now if they had decided to call it the
engagement that's crazy I feel like they
should have really called it off sooner
because like I know it wasn't right do
you don't I mean no you were their
biggest support I was their biggest
supporter but like you can't change man
but she changed a man really because
she's not married so it doesn't look
like much changed
I don't know seemingly acknowledging the
Harper 82 significance of the day Cena
wrote that it was quote important to
keep moving even when life seems to
throw misfortunes across your path he
tweeted this literally on the day he was
supposed to get married at 956 oh yeah
like he was thinking about it all day if
you choose to keep moving no matter how
low the road takes you it will
eventually begin to climb back up
hashtag and never give up
like when they looking at pictures then
I'm like so sad what is he hoping for
himself that he's gonna find someone
else that doesn't want to have kids like
and he that he's gonna love someone more
than he loves Nikki Bella like how is
that even possible so one day earlier
Cena and Bella also appeared to
acknowledge the importance of may faith
when they both shared cryptic messages
on Instagram they told a Bellas star
posted an image of a quote which read
chin up princess or the crown slips Cena
opted to share a close-up image of day
zero a book by Kresley Cole about the
apocalypse john susan surrounds out of
control have you seen it no it's too
it's too much for me I don't like know
enough about honestly this is like
middle school type [ __ ] like makeup
in real life or stop posting things on
Instagram I just um I just don't know
what his endgame is you know look I
gotta make sure my girlfriend you know
whether he needs to be it oh my god I
the perfect match for John Cena
Stacy Keibler she's also a wrestler she
was also a permanent she was a
professional girlfriend
yeah but she's my kids now when I look
at pictures of John Cena and Nikki Bella
like it makes me really sad she was
meant to be Nikki Cena know she was like
they were the Queen like no I wouldn't
you know how I'm turning wrecker and he
was like you could be my CrossFit Queen
yeah the CrossFit world that was a two
of them WWE no it's just like he's the
quarterback and she's the head
cheerleader do you know what I mean no
it just is and I was just really happy
who was he gonna find she beat the
system like when she did it she like
moved into that house in Tampa like she
did it she works so hard and she did it
and she deserves half of his fortune
it's not about he's [ __ ] he's so
ready yeah that's a great guy
but he's such a great guy she would have
done anything for him and so like what
she would have had to do is do not have
children and no one should do that and
like most they don't want you can't love
John more than she would love like her
potential children maybe he was meant to
be with Cal rads well maybe and we're
gonna the actually cuz he just wants a
perma girlfriend and she just wants like
a casual he doesn't want to live with he
don't want to live with Nikki she
doesn't want to work without a couch
perfect perfect
hmm I love a happy ending I just know
I'm not over at this I feel like this
story's not over I
I completely agree like the book has not
closed on these two you know what if
this was a movie she would move on with
her life oh you fall in love with in the
end we'd be laughing watching the sunset
fade to black
show the names say that happy are you
ever singing a song in your surprise
when you know the next layer that's all
the time that was one of those
situations we'd have had something else
oh so if this was a movie no singing she
wouldn't move on and get married
instantly like have kids like find out
she wasn't happy and like five and ten
years later like be single with a kid
she got what she wanted and then she'd
be able to go back to John yeah but does
John want to be a step down okay look he
needs to meet us halfway like he just
want to be over your father he'd be at
least a stepfather totally and it's not
to say we tacked on to say that
stepfathers aren't real fathers because
I know people especially Meghan King
Edmonds already
sensitive about that and I'm not trying
to offend anyone anymore especially in
five years like the hard work is over
the diapers are changed up like you're
into the face of throwing a football
with your son so yeah I think he wants
to be there for that part I just like
I'm just really like I want her to win
you know what I mean
no she will I mean we should all support
her like like she has that line of like
lingerie birdie-birdie be let's all
support it okay I think she's time
finance you know it's not about
financially it's about emotions and like
professionally like we need to make her
bigger than John Cena said he's like
crawling back to her when you think that
would be so hard he's literally the
richest man we need to get her in movies
no no we need to get her invested in the
tech startup that has like a huge she
needs um she needs a video game like
like him like a Kardashian and while
we're at it we should have tiffany
thornton get involved also and Nikki
Bella needs to come out with like a line
of shoes for Kmart no no I'm sorry a
line of work out where for Kmart and
Macy's making that Jessica Simpson money
and making a JLo money oh my god I'm
literally laughing so hard this is a
thornton is doing really well like I
follow her now and she gets a lot of
Instagram ads I know and I she get some
Planet Fitness what's a gold it doesn't
matter what's the one that all the
Bachelor people do then leap on a vanity
planet bless critten yeah okay third
story via TMZ blac Chyna she's worthless
but I'm the precise spot vanity con its
F Margo good for ya I think she's like
she was Lauren B's code yeah yeah I
remember blac Chyna's value has
plummeted only pot at clubs across
America and the reason is simple her
wagon has been unhitched from the
Kardashians black time is turning 30
next week we're told she spread the word
to promoters she's available for club
bookings we did a little digging and
turns out Chyna's earning power has
fizzled since breaking up with Rob
Kardashian
unless wage Inc courtroom more counts it
doesn't the numbers are staggering bout
weed this is unbelievable BC also known
as blac Chyna went from booking gigs
that paid her up to 30 K not too long
ago in her heyday with Rob and crew to
now struggling to snag more than 7k a
gig that's so sad
that's what several top club promoters
and told us and Callie told us and it
gets worse one promoter said he wouldn't
pay her penny more than five thousand
because China but that Rob is like Sonny
without Cher
I taught Miami promoter said he'll test
Sonny the max he'd shell out is 2k
because she's not relevant anymore
China's new boo isn't helping financial
matters either this according to one
promoter who said her relationship with
18 year old rapper ybn on my DJ who
can't even get into 21 and over club
it's just whack OMG the finances of
being an Instagram thought never cease
to amaze me never cease to amaze I feel
like the value she brings is like I
would pay to see blac chyna because I
just want to see what she actually looks
like hit the post on instagram with they
see uh-oh I just find the shocking it's
like I know how much they pay like
Instagram people and like I'm through a
post and I'm fairly familiar like with
the market and I find the shocking I
thought that even in her heyday should
be making way more than 30 I agree well
especially if she's with Rob right but
like do you remember this is my like the
most sad story like the reason why China
robber never meant to be together are
you ready you're gonna be really sad
like right when they started dating and
like right when she had a tiny bump she
got booked for a appearance in Vegas at
like some really hoochie like low-grade
place and TMZ found out that like oh man
this is so sad so the venue flew out
this was like a her top shoot they flew
first-class and Rob came with her and
they didn't fly Rob out and Rob meant to
say coach why yeah and there was the
higher like but he wasn't being paid
though it was just China but like he
couldn't afford first class what about
that Arthur George money I'm just saying
how's that is that it's so sad that Rob
was literally a gifted a sock line he's
like small dream and he like can't even
show up to the factory do we only have
four story isn't that big story because
no well there's one more here oh okay do
the force right and then I'll tell you
what the history is cuz you forgot okay
guys ready for a fourth story are you
feeling so far I'm feeling okay but I
just weird we done talking about robbing
China oh no sorry keep on know what time
how sad is that story it's like not that
sad what's sad is that like Rob can't
afford first class like yeah it's sad
for the Kardashians not for Rob because
they gave him everything on a silver
Potter yeah and like now we look back
the bars no drugs Arthur I'd say spike
I love iti either died stocks were sold
at the Khloe bookstore they were sold at
a Neiman Marcus but it definitely has
many another way to Hamilton New York
like how insane is that there's like so
I have no no sympathy for him if he
wanted to make money he cut up he
doesn't even push it on his Instagram
about the Sox like Chris does right yeah
no and but they're still
Arthur George Instagram account right no
it's like they're still making socks but
like it's a shell of a company maybe
it's a front I hope so
wouldn't that just be great if it like
went under another mattress firm
situation Chris would never let it go
under I think that's why she's
single-handedly keeping in a flow
because she won't let want to hurt the
business know she's mother day socks on
earth Oh George like that you were not
fooling anyone honestly it's probably a
money laundering thing a mattress firm
situation his mattress from what money
laundering have you not seen this read
the conspiracy theories Blake here's the
thing people the conspirator this is the
problem with the conspiracy theory it
started because people were so confused
why there's a mattress for him on every
corner what people don't know is
mattress firm as Sleepy's rebranded and
I went there and like they were really
amazing and delivered the next day and
like please okay just because you're a
friend doesn't mean you can't also
operate a good breast business I feel
like a lot of restaurants are friends
but like what if they don't think
sleepies was sleep is like the number
one not just bran in like the entire
country I don't know it's fishy it's not
it's not fishy I'm standing by mattress
for him they literally saved my life
on two occasions cuz you know me and Ben
broke our bed I dunno they delivered an
you look your mattress know the freight
like the whatever so we went they give
us a new thing we broke it again how
just living on it like that's how you
know we need to lose weight
where was the front mattress her maybe
they meant to change it no they came fix
it two seconds ESA no there should have
shetan that I don't know because he's a
friend
okay Story number four from page six
Adele turns 30 with Titanic themed
birthday party I love this story
Adele was the queen of the world at her
Titanic themed birthday bash over the
weekend after turning the big three on
Saturday the British singer publicly
thanked loved ones for on Sunday for
fulfilling her wishes
this was her Instagram caption dirty 13
I'm not sure what I'm going to do for
the next two years as I've been blessed
beyond words with my life so far thank
you to everyone for coming along on the
ride the last 11 years with me my family
and friends and entertaining my super
fandom of the Titanic movie so she
dresses Kate Winslet's rose to it Bukit
era how do you bring up roses last name
just rose you cater
Buca turk growth do it okay either I
guess she's from Philadelphia
Oh locator yeah Adele pose for a photo
atop the stairwell that looked just like
the one in James Cameron epic 99
blockbuster film
Rumph sorry she's not from philadelphia
she was traveling there she was gonna
settle there but she was from British
yes I was from British so it looks like
one more fun fact that a short another
Adele and blac Chyna are the same age
and just text like blac Chyna's so much
more accomplished in a boat this is what
L said about her party last night was
the best man in my life here's a couple
pics I'm absolutely [ __ ] not sure I'll
make it out of the house again okay
here's the thing I feel like Adele gets
like Jackie O level yeah but like with
wine taupe I mean see it's a redhead
thing it's just like a sensitive
terrific woman thing totally her skin is
soft like butter and literally um here's
the thing I know Titanic is an amazing
movie but it was also a tragedy and like
that's like me literally like having a
Holocaust teams birthday party do you
any mean like people died I know buddy
else since that's weird yes and no yes
it's like the it's like a Titanic movie
themed birthday party so wouldn't be
like having a Holocaust theme and it
would be like having Schindler's List
themed weird no it's like having some
amazing is the greatest love story of
our time but like let's mean that
Freight like all the people and animals
who died the animals I can't in a chant
and I know it was a Kentucky jailer this
weekend but like when are we gonna stop
using animals for entertainment you
consider horses like animal abuse not
abuse but like and they really do take
really good care of animals they get
like they have lived better than us but
lately the bill life O'Reilly like if I
have a horse if I have a racehorse I'm
calling him Riley because he's living my
life Riley if I get a horse I'm naming
him Archie why I don't know I just like
the name it's a great name for an animal
perhaps that's the worst dog name and
I'm sorry but then Archie's dog's name
is Vegas who's Archie like Kappa Kappa
oh in the movie you guys Michelle is out
I'm so buddy has become like a
full-blown like not even horror show
like like terrorist show a really good
matchup this one is it's Harris with
also the worst a my of anyone because Oh
Myrna I go behind you need to catch up
it's not a priority
no it's not a see but now it is right or
rush is disappointed [ __ ] okay I promise
I will get back its
[ __ ] crazy like I have to prepare
myself I can't watch it alone either
mostly cuz I won't watch out Zach as he
would be like upset and also it's scary
and also it's scary like there's a loose
I used to not be able to watch Desperate
Housewives alone cuz used to good like
scared oh my god when there's a man in
the basement
yeah oh my god Jerry family yeah that
was so scary
it was last name she was always making
cherry pop what apples one thing yeah uh
she Appleby no apples something someone
what the cousins uncle it um but ya know
Desperate Housewives like started out
like cute and like Oh a housewife
committed suicide because she's gonna
take the pressures of being a housewife
and then it turned so dark like their
Bible white there was a baby buried in a
treasure chest under the pool Applewhite
a baby's bones buried in the treasure
chest under the pool and there's just
like so babies okay and there's like
you're not listening my baby's bones
measured under cherry Ches under the
pool I heard you don't even know I do
know this is the thing there's so many
amazing actors in that show I mean well
it's for certain greatest actors of our
generation Bree van de Kamp or no but
like she was never in anything ever
again like we only know Marcia Cross
even though she's from uh Melrose Place
okay Orson well yeah he's from like twin
peaks' and everything let's get it he
plays the same character I mean Eva
Longoria everything Felicity how did you
phrase your wife Madison did like Garza
Gabrielle Solis his daughter Juanita who
is also demidov Otto's stepsister
Frazier's wife Randy Huffman Camille
Grammer's oh wait what's fussy Hoffman's
husband William H Macy from Virginia
what is crazy beautiful ass crazy
grammar is for him oh my god wait we
have to keep going because currents
coming Corrine
oh wait you guys I showed you my family
she always cancels her birthday she
detects it us she's doing a taco theme
something is it is she going in or going
out with a bang in she's deciding
between uptown or downtown um who else
from that show
Oh teri hatcher who went nowhere uh that
is not true
she has a web show just like a it's like
a cooking we should do like a sweet life
of Hannah Montana with like Teri
Hatcher's web show and here ya know it's
actually very popular amongst
women 3548 oh yeah Congrats Terry Terry
is a horrible name I'm sorry if we've
and each other's name Terry like it's
literally a rough name like I can only
think when I think of Terry like
literally like a school principal do you
know it's a terrible it's a terrible
thing okay our fifth and final story is
only one that you have to see the
believe which is Becca kufran back all
right from right okay it's Nizam
depending what baby all right so she's
an independent woman who was literally
like doing anything to find a man which
is just I love the message you know it's
cohesive
I love women who's willing to embarrass
herself on national television in order
to find a man to marry in a month
oh I wasn't anywhere to take a bit
bye-bye they it's as I say school like
please let him live that I'm graduate
you guys what are you trying to stop a
man from getting his education yeah wait
that's what we're saying in a better
woman who needs a man I just want to say
like I'm not here for Becca Kay and I'm
ready to be proven wrong but like she's
so like regular and like everything
about it everything about it is regular
and like everything is just fine like
clean and she'll probably like meet a
man like they'll get married and live
forever like never have sex you know
need me looks like everything's just so
regular boring vanilla it would be the
word yeah that's what people said about
Ari and Lauren I don't care I love that
never Kenny my ass okay I think a fork I
really love them I only really love them
and like honestly the toasters hate them
and like they are perfect for each other
I'm the one in scramble and you want Ari
to choose Beca em and live the weird
like them make no sense every time like
they put up an Instagram like someone
screenshots and puts in the toasters and
all the toys like a basic lame listen
you guys we need to seriously rebrand
our thoughts on Ari and Lauren I love
them
also like every picture where you post
and you're like making fun of them they
both look beautiful and they look like
they're so happy they're living the life
or I'll eat on the racetrack in
Australia like getting free flights to
Finland not even [ __ ] know either of
them no but why do I feel like we know
that I don't have met Arie you didn't
they both follow me on Instagram and on
it's a sudden tars gems and he did not
answer which was never open it
that's really sad oh he was getting so
much it I was like honestly like I just
want you know I can love you and Lauren
I'm like I hope you guys have a happy
life together
and looks like a nice message I think
respond to that I think that they will
have a happy life together just because
they want to prove me wrong everyone
wrong like sometimes that can be such a
significant Drive warden and jojo barton
Jojo and even Rachel and Bryan because
like they everyone thought everyone
thought the cheat but I think also she
just like also happens to love him
dearly I am absolutely in love with
Rachel insane and no one could say
anything bad about her I will literally
come to your house and murder Gayle and
I just want to go jealous like party
with her and Raven and Alexis did Alexis
move to Dallas I was gonna DM heard the
same thing because when I did my my
Instagram story like vote like where
should you my next thing she responded
Dallas knows and she's there with Rachel
like doing a workout - I know - she
posted pictures with Raven in Real
Housewives of Dallas I just need to know
I just I agree anyway and by the way and
I think Rachel Lindsay's promo was one
of my favorites that's my girl that's
just it's that song with that thing of
her also JoJo's wasn't bad confident by
Demi Lovato like things are the worse it
was okay things she was like no but that
was when you loved her like if she was
coming off of Ben's season she was like
we got robbed
yeah rising from the ashes confident it
was just a great time to be alive no I'm
like I just I watch Rachel's all the
time
I also um try not to cringe but let's do
the damn thing Oh God
now we're cursing on cable please what
is this world to come to I'm just saying
people don't like the word damn
especially the the bachelor nation is
like very like American and I just
something they're gonna like these so
the D word they should have gone with
darn pulled the Hannah Montana yes or do
the dirty or just completely instead of
instead of not using the word damn maybe
they should have completely rebranded
the entire thing and maybe rethought who
they would choose as their bachelor or
just take out that one line because I
literally hate that line do you like who
would you have preferred us about chart
Becca K or Becca Becca K because I know
Becca M is I just like feel like she
watches everything that's said about her
Jackie's Cerny has some insight on
Alexis she said she isn't loving LA she
talked about it on Kaitlyn's podcast and
said she wants to move to Dallas I'm
here their boyfriends family's from
Dallas right I don't know why she I
thought she had ties to Dallas some
people just have she was like yeah I
some people just have ties to Dallas
like me okay
so that ends our five mm-hmm
that's high stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast we are going
to take a quick break and when we return
we will be back with Corrine elympios
from bachelor and about trim paradise if
you have any requests or question if you
have any questions for current about
dating lies bachelors stuff I don't know
what else you could think of feel free
to drop it in the comments I'm watching
on Facebook I will do everything I can
to get them to cran we're really excited
that she's here so we will see you in a
few minutes
you
oh hey we are back on the morning toast
with our favorite guest Colonel up yes
oh I'm so good how are you we're so
happy that you're here I'm really happy
to be here oh my gosh like what why it's
been a while I'm like what is up with
corn so I've just been living life yeah
I am single and I'm just working on my
projects and just do you prefer to be
signal I'm having a lot of fun being
single right now
because I feel like I just went through
a lot this last year with like paradise
and yeah my ex-boyfriend and then dating
someone new and then getting into like
the tabloids and freaking out at me it's
just like I'm like just doing me and I
just feel really good about it
yes well you look so good and you did
light in your hair yes yes I'm
lightening my hair gray white ash is it
like giving you an alter you go like I
feel really hot yeah I feel so hot I'm
just texting my sister I'm like Taylor
you don't understand my eyes are popping
okay
like it's so true have you ever been a
hair color other than blonde or is this
the first time no no no this is this is
like really stepping out of my comfort
zone yeah
hairstylist was like I really don't want
to do this crane you're gonna hate it
like I'm really scared I'm like no no we
got this
yeah no it looks really good I'm getting
a major Ariana Grande vibes okay we're
like hers like in high pony ever
I think so I mean first I gotta get the
color right yeah I need to be a little
bit lighter but I wouldn't like toning
it was like blue shampoo yes
so you'll get there yeah takes time I
would say it's like the number one
question we offer you on social media
it's like what's goin on with you and
tomorrow because our yeah yeah because
you guys hang out all the time who
challenged our together okay and it's
just like after everything that happened
in Paradise it's like an unlikely duo a
hundred percent and I agree with that
but Demario and I are are really close
friends yeah and so I ran into him
weekend one at Coachella and and jasmine
and everybody and we were just like
let's go we can - yeah
it wasn't like a thing like we were with
other people too we went with like
Vernon Davis and his girlfriend which
he's so nice by the way
and yeah we're just friends okay good
social media can make it seem different
everyone like once you guys today yeah
it's just not it's on the course it's
it's not no I I just don't see that
happening I just care too much about him
as a friend and that's it no I like you
guys as friends
I'm here for you have friends or former
friends we got a lot of questions about
GG from sir
yeah a former assistant mr. Graham story
what yes okay so she's one of the
toasters posted it in the toaster script
this night everyone should be in the
toaster super cross I was in it when she
posted like a DM where someone asked her
if she was still your assistant and she
said no I was never her assistant I was
just like her paid to be her friend and
that she was in a podcast and talked
about it she was gonna doesn't explain
to everyone what happened between wow
it's really crazy how much she's really
trying to like what how it happened we
met her she when you were on our camera
it was definitely my assistant she
actually turned out to be really really
nasty person Chuck and I'm really
surprised that I'm even hearing that she
had the balls to go on social media and
talk about it yeah Wow
I'm like really like wow yeah and so you
didn't let her go like no I didn't just
let her go I'm not that kind of person I
actually dealt with a lot of attitude
and my manager was like it got to a
point where like everyone around me was
a Krynn you need to not be afraid of
your assistant like I I really was like
afraid of her I'd be like are you okay
like what it like oh good are you sure
like where did you want to eat today I
like oh my god I'm shocked well I
literally was like a doormat right right
it just got to a point where was just
like insane so I paid for her to come to
Aspen with me and so over New Year's and
I was like at that point she was just
giving me so much attitude and I'm like
it's either gonna be a huge blowout
fight yeah or we're gonna just like
squash everything
and of course we got into a huge blowout
fight her and my friend got into a
really bad altercation and I just yeah
there were there were hands thrown shook
I'm so shocked because I think you
didn't know I've been really respectful
of keeping her situation private from
the public right because it's really
embarrassing it is but you didn't know I
had no idea that she spoke anything
about it no and I really don't like
someone saying wow that is honestly like
I'm like I'm actually like really mad
right I'm sorry no no that's really but
I saw the comments on Instagram I'm like
why are people talking about that oh
yeah
I went on Sheena's podcast and all I
said was that word just I don't work
with me more and I we're not friends and
I don't like her that's it so she used
to work at Sur I guess I didn't even
know that she was the host that like
Jane [ __ ] with when oh really yeah I
believe so when he had all those
scratches on I heard she tried to go
back to sur and like they didn't let her
somebody show even if I never why are we
even talking yeah I'll show you all she
do remember she took the mic last time
we were on here in G all she wanted was
to be in the spotlight oh my gosh you
guys when we were here I told her about
courtesan just beaten corn and like
Olivia used to like be behind the camera
in like we would need to give her a mic
because like you need me what she was
saying and the scrubbing took the mic
and started talking on the show um ah no
dude no you have no idea that's like not
even have it she literally wanted to
like steal like my thunder always I'm
like first of all I took her to a
meeting about a snapchat show and it was
a really big meeting and this girl is
fighting with the producer stop moving
at each other from across the table
getting into politics I'm like first of
all why are you even talking right
she blew that deal for me right don't
even get me started on her so first of
all let's not even talk about her she
yes all she wants is that right Society
yeah yeah your podcast yes so random I
was on it yes yes yes how's it going and
were you on Spencer's or was Spencer on
yours cuz you're booking the podcast one
right yeah I was on Spencer's I'm
hiding inside yeah their son is so cute
Oh see son yes oh my God where did you
feel that Julian in the studio yeah oh
my god and was he there
this hey oh this I'm Gunnar yes boys
Heidi was like doing the podcast like
wrapping herself like with the baby like
my G work oh my god she was I was just
like you are like Wonder Woman right yes
so clean yeah I love them until how's
the podcast going it's going really
really well um actually I'm gonna be
making an announcement hopefully soon
make it right now please I really want
you I just don't know if I'm allowed -
you're gonna be changing my podcast up
basically we're gonna be doing a special
with like another news outlet where it's
gonna be like either like a once a month
or once a week type of podcast show
miniseries thing oh [ __ ] that's someone
really cool so it's so cool that's
really excited and then my book Chuck
yeah so my book was getting to the point
where it was just like too funny
honestly oh my god honey that's s with
you like I agreed like this show is too
funny but like sometimes I would like be
working with my ghostwriter and I'm like
I can't even believe that this happened
to me yeah so we decided to make my book
a fiction about a fictional character
and it's gonna be about me but it's like
we're turning it into a story about a
character that's so Kendall and Kylie
yeah really yeah they like a book like
that like two girls like in LA I didn't
even know I'm so into Amanda Stanton is
also writing a book do you guys get
together and like write at Circo
actually actually no we don't but you
should I know we really should she's
working with a different ghostwriter
yeah I'm actually met her randomly chose
the gum riding mammoths bug I'm like hey
[Music]
the ones you're booking to come out well
it was supposed to come out by the end
of this year and now since we're kind of
like
rebranding it a little bit I'm not
exactly sure I do want it to be perfect
though before you put it out so good
time I'm gonna find out soon and be
announcement that's so exciting love
announcement I love uncle bachelor alum
books I read them all yeah so would you
ever do like a tell-all no no like about
paradise nothing are you over it
I'm really would you go back to paradise
I would go back to paradise I don't have
I would do anything with a bachelor fan
yeah I love my bachelor family what you
know something funny yes I just say I
think this is really funny I can't tell
if you're about to see something funnier
be like this is funny I think you mean
like I'm no it's just my friends who I'm
staying with here um one of the guys
went out to dinner last night literally
left the building and FaceTime me he's
like Nick literally just walked right by
me oh my god everyone sees Nick
everyone's amazed like I've not seen
Nick since after the final rose what not
one time all my friends are like oh my
god I just on it oh my god I really I'm
like literally how like I really just
with you like it's the weird like not
even at Coachella yeah thing never one
time and all my friends see him all
they're like so weird it's like I'm just
a universal to go on but you guys are in
good terms right yeah I think so like if
you saw him you would like him hug yeah
I would I would okay are you on good
terms with most of your the girls that
were on your season yeah yeah I think
anyone like you hate it or that hates
you you know I think everyone's over the
whole hating thing I just think it's
like a mutual known thing that some of
the girls and I just don't get along
because lately some things that were
said after paradise look who I think I'd
probably say like Raven and Danielle
like I'm I've went out of my way to try
to like men's things with Danielle and
it's just like not gonna work yeah like
at this point I'm like on better terms
like Vanessa Wow shut up crazy
yeah I'm not even on good terms with
Vanessa or I don't think she died so I
have I just really hate her okay dead
let's play game [ __ ] marry kill
Oh last time I did this I made headlines
that I wanted to kill Meryl Streep oh
let's hope that this happens yeah we
love headlines okay you have Nick bile
okay
you have tamari oh okay and
you Alex Wieck you said he was on
paradise with you it's a really short
guy like yeah no I don't know wasn't he
oh okay
[ __ ] Mike oh oh wait who was no one Mick
Demario Alex okay I think well I think I
would marry Alex um I was just gonna say
we're all agree that we're gonna kill
out I hope he's like really really
really I had a really deep talk with him
like if you like tried to kiss me or
anything he was so respectful if you
killed him like fake he would be upset I
think so but like where is he even he's
a marine the corner
oh is it I feel like on Instagram yes
he's on inside yeah
I'm to follow him I think I do follow
him I don't get your magic Alex okay I
am going to kill Nick of course yeah
actually you didn't have sex just so
everybody knows we did not have sex
Oh a paradise you're saying yes we made
out yes who cares and stuff and stuff et
Cie period at all at all well that's I
ship you guys I'm happy I'm really happy
for you guys you never know you really
never know have you met Arie I have not
met our did you watch his season as much
as I could right I just really the whole
yeah you know I feel like once you're on
it like you can't even begin to just
watch it and like and they have real
fake it is yeah you just like know
everything that's happening that yeah
it's just you're like like if that was
this person yeah saying this you know
what you mean it's just like Gary I
don't know once once you're on something
it's like I feel like that was a reality
TV I was watching X on the beach last
night and I was just like I can't even
watch reality no I summon each is
especially bad have you would you ever
go out there I was asked to go on it oh
I'm sure and I didn't go on it yeah and
are you good for Jasmine she that's
amazing she's great on any show she's
ever this is like a little too weird for
me I tried to watch the first episode
now watch anything like I even watch are
you the one so like I know all those
people and I just
feeling the Edit so don't think it's
weird when they're like are you the one
influencer this that and then it's like
The Bachelor I'm like yeah what about
Vanderpump rules it looks so bad I think
all in all honestly like I love my
bachelor family love love love so much
it's where corn was born yeah okay I
will always love them so much but I just
really feel like they aren't just
killing the Fran I be like get your [ __ ]
together it's so what do you think that
they could do to make it better
unfortunately I just think that the show
is just going a different direction and
how the show used to be whether it was
like really magical about love very very
serious instead of it being more about
reality TV and like what goes on how
yeah it was never about that until
recent season yeah yeah there's always a
good balance of like the stupid drama
but then also like the real love and
we're now less endure less yeah the real
love and like I feel like we haven't
seen like anything like magical yeah and
it's like it's just the girls are just
getting younger and younger sillier and
sillier and just like it's like the
things they're doing after like I just
feel like I don't know I feel like it's
getting less and less respected and it
makes me sad honest yeah like I'm like
Hello Mike Fleiss like what are you
doing what are your thoughts on Mike
Fleiss I to see the devil I don't really
know him have you met him no oh really
that's crazy you know I never met have
you met him no but now Kaitlynn told us
she met him when she was chosen to be
the bachelor and they had like a really
scary meeting in his office like scary
because he scared even do anything like
I feel like he is yes I would not take
anything with him he's so scary know
what if he wanted me to be the
Bachelorette
oh dude in two seconds what do you think
about Becca it's about red happy for her
she seems like a really sweet person I
just I don't know I just think she's a
little bit I think she's an amazing
person and boring yeah that's what week
that's all regular yeah so from now on
who from re-season would you think would
have made a better Bachelorette are you
friendly with any of those girls Becca
am I
interviews with Becca she's sweet yeah I
mean I don't really have a issue with
anyone I just don't I just didn't think
that that season was more interesting or
even re it was all of them it wasn't
like anyone in particular was she that
whole yeah than like The Bachelor sucked
the girls stuff yeah like if they tried
to make drama out of like no no it was
just stupid yeah yeah so okay you're so
funny
okay I had a question and I literally
forgot it take your time no it was
important it's always important it's
always important I can't remember okay
well thank you so much for joining us if
Claudia remembers her question Jacob see
Emmett CEO and like you'll and then we
can post it yeah yeah it was important
it was like something about Raven right
you know I like along those lines like
friends girls like oh well this isn't it
but you watched Fraser right oh my god
we were just talking about this we hate
Fraser we must eat it we've never seen
it but oh my god however we think of
like we're like who watches Fraser we
know you watch radio yeah you're the
only person me Niles crane is a
literally my spirit who's that
he is Frazier's brother on the show
who's preacher's wife Fraser does not
have his own ex-wife and she is epic
well turning okay her name is Lilith and
who plays with Lilith she's she's an
actual Lilly
he's a Lillis of a woman is there one
episode that you would recommend us to
watch like if we work together what's
your favorite episode my favorite
episode of Frasier is probably the one
where Niles is getting ready for a date
because he had just broken up with his
wife and he's like trying to iron his
suit and he burns his finger any faint
and then he wakes up and he realized he
burns his fingers he faints again it's
really just such a nice thing it sounds
terrible but I'll watch all of my god
it's so good though it's frustrating
when you love a show and like you're
trying to get someone like I love
friends and like Jackie doesn't do you
like Jewish friends who doesn't like me
yeah yeah my god I think it's so
annoying with the laugh tracks in the
burrito she's out of control there's so
many she's you see the Saturday Night
Live of like the girl making fun of
Rachel's
[Laughter]
oh good it's so good to catch up
everyone please give it up for current
Queen where can everyone follow you on
social media here updates about the
podcast about the book okay podcast is
so random
with podcast one and my Instagram is C
Olympius and my twitter is Corinne
Olli urban Olli give it up everyone we
are Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time we are live on YouTube on
Facebook and then available on the
podcast app at the morning toast to make
sure you like us on Facebook subscribe
to us on YouTube
and leave a review about how beautiful
stunning and gorgeous we are on our
podcast page we will see you tomorrow we
hope you have an amazing week bye
you